y
[Música]
la batalla por el donbass ha comenzado
así lo alertó el presidente de ucrania
huele vivir silencia y quien afirmó que
la ofensiva a gran escala de las tropas
rusas para controlar el este plan ya no
ya comenzó
jornada de hoy fueron registrados
continuos bombardeos en esa zona del
país también en el oeste en la ciudad de
lviv se registraron cinco ataques con
misiles que dejaron al menos siete
muertos tenemos reporte de nuestros
enviados especiales
a sólo seis días de la segunda vuelta de
las presidenciales francesas la mayoría
de los partidarios del izquierdistas ran
look melón son asegura que votaría en
blanco o preferiría la abstención antes
que dar su apoyo a manuel ma con imagine
lo que es la primera vuelta melanson
pidió que ningún voto fuera a la extrema
derecha
en méxico la reforma energética
impulsada por el presidente andrés
manuel lópez obrador se hundió en el
congreso el resultado se esperaba por lo
que el mandatario ya había anunciado su
plan b que consiste en que el estado sea
el único que pueda explotar el litio el
llamado por hombre oro blanco mexicano
tenemos análisis
en france 24 estamos de vuelta con las
noticias que marcan la jornada soy
valentina torre sánchez y es un gusto
acompañarlos actualizamos la información
de la invasión rusa ucrania que completó
su día número 54 el presidente vladimir
selenski anunció que ya comenzó la
ofensiva rusa en el este del país las
autoridades ucranianas revelaron que el
ejército de vladimir putin intensificó
sus bombardeos en la región del donbass
con ataques a jarquín con jets y lugansk
las tropas rusas también lanzaron
bombardeos hoy en los alrededores del
río de mipro cerca a kiev y también
moscú volvió a acercarse a la frontera
de ucrania con la unión europea al
lanzar misiles sobre el biv que dejaron
al menos siete civiles muertos y otras
11 personas heridas en medio de cinco
ataques con misiles sin embargo según la
versión rusa los bombardeos se
produjeron contra un centro de armas
supuestamente provenientes del
extranjero que habían llegado al país en
los últimos días escuchamos las palabras
del mandatario ucraniano
para sobornar constató bate ser si es
que ahora ya podemos afirmar que las
tropas rusas comenzaron la batalla por
el donbass para lo cual se han estado
preparando durante mucho tiempo una
parte significativa de todo el ejército
ruso ahora se concentra en esta ofensiva
es que youtube es dueña de reses que
gris cubo no importa cuántas tropas
rusas lleven allí lucharemos nos
defenderemos y lo haremos todos los días
no renunciaremos a ninguna parte de
ucrania y no necesitamos nada extranjero
altus prost tener por triple hablamos
ahora de francia en donde los aspirantes
a las presidenciales en marie le pen y
el actual presidente de manuel ma con
aspirantes a la reelección se disputan
los votos del candidato de izquierdas
run look me now son ahora cuando faltan
sólo seis días para la segunda vuelta
presidencial que será llevada a cabo el
partido de izquierda a franklin sumisa
realizó una consulta que arrojó como
resultado que el 37% de sus seguidores
votará en blanco en el balotaje del 24
de abril
a quién votarán los simpatizantes de
jean-luc mélenchon en segunda vuelta al
24 de abril eso fue lo que le pregunto
francia insumisa al partido de mel en
son más de 310.000 personas que apoyaron
su candidatura en la primera vuelta los
resultados reflejaron el sentir del
grueso de sus electores en los últimos
días ni mccrone ni lepén dos tercios de
los consultados dijeron que votarían en
blanco o se abstendrían las encuestas
que darían así el 37 6% de los votos
serían en blanco o nulo 33 4 por ciento
de los apoyos irían a enmanuel macrón y
28 9 no votarían pero la encuesta no es
vinculante ni completa siguiendo la
directriz de merenson de no dar un voto
a la extrema derecha no se preguntó
sobre un posible voto por le pen que
sigue luchando por absorber votos de la
izquierda una tarea que no es imposible
yo creo que eso puede pasar por una
sencilla razón que uno mira la política
el programa de
los
que hay mucha coincidencia con lepe
en cuestiones de la sociedad la salida
de la otan y todas esas cosas hace que
los votantes podían inclinar por lepe
pero ahora la contrincante de manuel
macrón tiene otros problemas el domingo
el sitio web mediapart publicó un
informe de la oficina antifraude de la
unión europea en el se investiga al epen
por casi 137 mil euros que presuntamente
malversó cuando era eurodiputada entre
2004 y 2017 la candidata rechazó la
publicación este lunes durante su visita
a sant pierre sur dif en el noreste de
francia dos grupos en su creo que los
franceses no se dejan engañar en
absoluto obviamente rechazó estas
acusaciones de las que no estaba al
tanto que ya plantean un problema en
términos de estado de derecho de lo cual
no se me proporcionó ninguna prueba
ningún elemento a pesar de las
solicitudes que pude hacer en el marco
de la campaña donde acompañó entretanto
una nueva encuesta de ipsos supra esther
ya dio ventaja macrón sobre el epen con
el 56% en la segunda vuelta
atravesamos el atlántico y llegamos a
américa latina' puntualmente a méxico
donde el presidente andrés manuel lópez
obrador sufrió un revés en la cámara de
diputados tras hundirse su reforma
eléctrica para analizar esta información
conectamos con gustavo rentería él es
analista político y periodista mexicano
bienvenido a france 24 que tanto le
afecta este resultado contrario al
presidente de lópez obrador
qué tal buenas noches un saludo alto
amplísimo auditorio de france 24
un saludo hasta bogotá desde san miguel
allende guanajuato a ver es un golpe muy
fuerte para el titular del ejecutivo
federal hoy prácticamente todos los
titulares de los periódicos las
redacciones de radio de televisión
comenzaron en su teaser con la
información de que había perdido la
votación de la reforma energética el
presidente de izquierda pero poco tiempo
le duró el triunfo a la oposición porque
ayer por la noche el presidente envió
una reforma a la ley minera y hace
apenas unas horas a que nuestro país se
acaba de aprobar que la exploración la
explotación y el aprovechamiento del
litio es exclusivo del estado mexicano
para darnos una idea y ponerlo en
contexto valentina hace 16 meses una
tonelada de litio valía 7 mil dólares
americanos hoy padrés 78 mil dólares me
explican los especialistas que este
mineral
almacena la energía y se está utilizando
sobre todo en la industria de los
teléfonos inteligentes y de los
automóviles eléctricos y ahí hay un gran
negocio creo que el presidente ayer fue
derrotado pero hoy te levanta con una
victoria muy importante vale pero es
decir este plan b que anuncia el
mandatario sobre el litio ya que ha
aprobado ya empieza a entrar en vigor
efe únicamente falta que vaya al senado
de la república y es mero trámite
valentín a la cámara de origen fue la
cámara de los diputados donde por cierto
la oposición encabezada por el perredé
y se dice de izquierda a la derecha
encabezada por
acción nacional y el pri que gobernó por
más de 70 años salieron del pleno de la
cámara de los diputados ya fue aprobar y
ahora va al senado de la república donde
morena y sus aliados junto con el pp y
verde ecologista lo van a aprobar es
decir es mero trámite hay que recordar
que la diferencia entre la reforma
energética y la reforma minera que hoy
se aprobó en la cámara de los diputados
es que la primera necesitaba un cambio
constitucional y una mayoría calificada
es decir tres cuartas partes en el caso
de la minera el simple 50 +1 le da la
oportunidad al presidente de la
república de que después de que vaya al
senado se publique en el diario oficial
de la federación y en ese momento entre
en vigor quería valentina y volviendo un
poco a este revés qué implicaciones
tienen términos políticos que la
oposición se haya unido y haya logrado
frenar una iniciativa impulsada por el
presidente
sin duda alguna es un golpe muy
importante severo para el presidente de
la república pero
algunos exageran desde mi punto de vista
de que ya se acabó el obradorismo en
mexico a ver esto es una falacia es una
tontería
el presidente tiene el control del
aparato efectivo no tiene la mayoría
calificada pero si la mayoría simple en
la cámara de los diputados y en mexico
se van renovando los órganos
constitucionales autónomos de manera
alternada y el presidente envía a la
cámara
del senado oa la cámara de los diputados
e
intenta potenciar sus propuestas y se
van renovando para el 2024 cuando será
la elección presidencial prácticamente
tendrá el control de todo valentina y en
escasas 56 semanas en méxico va a haber
elecciones para renovar gobernadores de
seis estados hay que recordar que
tenemos 32 entidades pero y ellas van a
ser renovadas en nuestro país y todas
las encuestas todos los ejercicios
demoscópicos hablan de que cuatro de los
va a quedar morena y únicamente dos la
oposición por cierto estos dos son
estados muy pequeños que no aportan
muchos votos ni mucho dinero a la
economía nacional los nombres son
aguascalientes y durango pero se
quedaría morena oaxaca quintana roo
donde destacan un el estado de hidalgo y
el estado de tamaulipas frontera con los
estados unidos y en el 2023 valentina
habrá dos selecciones
estarán en juego coahuila y el estado de
méxico james gray y gobernó 32 entidades
únicamente se va a quedar 2 coahuila y
el estado del señor rentería estas
muchas gracias por su análisis y por
compartirlo con nosotros en france 24
al contrario valentín es uno lo que me
permita dirigirme a tu arte público en
toda latinoamérica buenas noches buenas
noches en otras noticias integrantes de
diferentes comunidades de canadá se
tomaron las calles del centro de la
ciudad de toronto la más poblada del
país en rechazó las disculpas ofrecidas
por el papá francisco ante los miles de
casos de abuso por parte de religiosos a
menores de edad indígenas durante la
estancia de estos últimos en colegios
internados los manifestantes exigieron
justicia al tiempo que dieron muestras
de los nombres de los menores de edad
abusados
las comunidades indígenas de canadá
marcharon en toronto pidiendo justicia
por los abusos que sufrieron los niños a
manos de integrantes de la iglesia
católica
sufrieron los abusos de las escuelas
residenciales hace años pero también no
hace tanto así que estamos aquí para
honrarlos mostrarles respeto y
asegurarnos de que podemos exigir
justicia y concientizar sobre cómo hacer
justicia a estos niños
los manifestantes se reunieron frente a
la basílica san michele donde colgaron
los nombres de las 150.000 víctimas de
los religiosos el 1° de abril el papá
francisco se disculpó frente a
representantes indígenas de canadá por
la responsabilidad de miembros de la
iglesia católica en las atrocidades
perpetradas en estos internados verdad
el problema de conducta de higüey - por
la deplorable conducta de los miembros
de la iglesia católica pido perdón a
dios y quiero decirles de todo corazón
que estoy herido y me uno a mis hermanos
obispos canadienses para pedirles
disculpas fratelli de subijana
en el que del discurso pero la comunidad
pide justicia y rechaza estas disculpas
no aceptamos las disculpas del papá no
es una disculpa que hayan pedido los
supervivientes y es muy importante que
pongamos los supervivientes y sus deseos
en primer lugar fue una disculpa vacía y
nadie en nuestra comunidad la acepta
y se trata de escuelas creadas a partir
de 1880 por el gobierno canadiense y la
iglesia católica para forzar la
asimilación de los niños indígenas a la
cultura euro canadiense los niños fueron
separados de sus familias para unirse a
estos internados donde sufrieron entre
otras cosas abusos físicos y sexuales la
última escuela cero en
se cumplen cuatro años desde el inicio
de las protestas antigubernamentales en
nicaragua que dejaron a más de 350
muertos en 5 meses a causa de la
represión estatal
me duele respirar fue el último grito de
la adolescente álvaro conrado antes de
ser asesinado por la policía
nicaragüense durante el estallido social
antigubernamental en 2018 cuatro años
después su familia reclama justicia
todavía no hay un responsable de su
muerte nosotros pedimos justicia
de montecchia queremos saber la verdad
de lo de los acontecimientos en ese día
álvaro fue fue uno de los primeros
heridos de muerte porque fue herido a
aproximadamente como las once y media de
la mañana guardar entonces queremos este
la verdad y justicia en 2018 miles de
nicaragüenses salieron masivamente a las
calles de todo el país en contra de una
reforma del sistema de salud propuesta
por el ejecutivo de daniel ortega
durante cinco meses nicaragua se
paralizó las autoridades sandinistas
respondieron con una brutal represión
contra los manifestantes que dejó al
menos 355 muertos cientos de detenidos y
más de 100.000 exiliados según la
comisión interamericana de derechos
humanos justo rodríguez un agricultor de
69 años pasó ocho meses en prisión donde
enfermo y ahora sobrevive postrado a una
cama llegando adelante pero por qué me
llevaron a ir extraer todo chapa
y me dieron en
el suspiro agónico del estudiante sigue
resonando en el país en noviembre de
2021 ortega fue reelegido en el cargo en
unos comicios sin garantías democráticas
y con la gran parte de la oposición en
el exilio o presos más de 100 críticos
están en la cárcel en ese momento álvaro
conrado le dolía respirar porque una
bala había atravesado su garganta en
este momento los nicaragüenses
continuamos siendo atravesado por el
dolor por el llanto por las lágrimas
por el sufrimiento
ahí hay personas que que todavía no han
podido sanar ese dolor las
organizaciones de derechos humanos
denuncia que el gobierno nicaragüense
sigue tratando de silenciar las voces
críticas y se han prohibido las
conmemoraciones por el aniversario del
levantamiento social
es todo por el momento en france 24
[Música]